pour évoquer la situation italienne nous
sommes en direct avec jonathan l'eau
bâti maire de l'ena dans la province de
bergame bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france 3 145 décès
enregistrés en italie c'est dernières 24
heures on a eu pourtant des luttes aux
bonnes nouvelles dans la journée
l'épidémie les courbes qui semblait un
petit peu baissé quelles sont quelle est
la situation sur place
bonsoir à tous la situation est encore
aujourd'hui d'extrême urgence
on a aujourd'hui un peu plus de 2500
morts c'est vrai qu'il est numéro aux
prix des jeux toujours et ils vont un
peu mieux mais c'est quand même
situations d'urgence qui restent à
bergame le centre de l'urgence est de
coronavirus sont toute l'italie
alors il ya eu effectivement ces mesures
de confinement très sévère chez vous un
confinement total mis en place il ya
déjà plusieurs jours responchons
commence déjà à en voir les effets
positifs
oui ont sûrement il ya beaucoup de monde
qui a déchiré décidé de rester à la
maison et dans quelques jours j'espère
déjà de demain qu'on va avoir des effets
positifs sur le nombre de personnes qui
ont été testés positifs
alors malgré cela ce n'est pas encore le
pic de l'épidémie vous quelle est la
situation dans votre village comment
vous vous organiser avec ces mesures de
confinement mis en place le 8 mars chez
nous on a six personnes qui ont été
testés positifs au corps un navire uss
quatre personnes qui sont
pas là car la quarantaine chez eux et
peuvent pas sortir de maison et après on
hier on a vu une carrière d'une personne
qui est décédée et par les mesures
contre ans en à rendre sur le territoire
c'est avec la sécurité civile avec la
police avec les gendarmes
le transfert du surveillance sur le
territoire on a même on va faire les
commissions pour les familles pour les
personnes âgées perdent les personnes
qu'ils ont plus de 65 ans ont porté les
commissions la maison comment le vivent
les italiens est ce qu'ils sont en
accord avec ces mesures prises par le
gouvernement ou comme en france on voit
ici ou là quelques critiques
sûrement les italiens qui comprend la
situation est un peu la peur en paix les
numéros ils ont fait comprendre tout le
monde que c'est faux c'est l'unique
solution qu'on peut prendre en ce moment
ça va
il n'y a pas des grosses polémiques sur
ça quelle est la situation dans les
hôpitaux on sait qu'elle est et qu'elle
est certainement encore dramatique on
parle voilà deux témoignages assez
poignant des médecins qui doit faire des
choix entre différents malades
est-ce que ça semble toujours le cas
notamment près de votre village oui
aujourd'hui il ya eu la notice que le
grand l'hôpital de bergame l'ospedale et
unity il peut plus recevoir des
personnes dans les soins intensifs ghana
80 jusque dans ce type d'hôpital et
d'admis il va voir un deuxième hôpital
qui est mis en place par l armée où il y
aura 40 e place d'autre que super yam
sur milan aussi il va voir un deuxième
hôpital avec 400 points place en plus
qu'est-ce que aujourd'hui vous attendez
du gouvernement c'est qu'en france il y
à l'armée qui
réagit qui intervient notamment dans une
de nos provinces les plus touchées pour
faire des hôpitaux de campagne est ce
que ce genre de situation de solutions
plus tôt et il est elle envisageable en
italie également
oui sûrement on a déjà beaucoup de
personnes mais qui vient de l'armée qui
sont au service dans les hôpitaux
italiens à bergame et ya vingt médecins
qui vient de l'armée qui sont venir
donner et soutien aux médecins pour
suivre tous les personnes qui sont dans
les soins intensifs merci beaucoup et
j'en attends le bâti merde dans la
province de bergame en italie nous avoir
apporté votre témoignage et bon courage
à vous aussi et ce témoin